now we know because we're actually in 3d
vectors right
what this is really shorthand for is um
for example you've got some x some y sum
z
right and what they're equal to is some
other vector some arbitrary vector right
so i guess maybe i'll call this x1
y1 z1 right
plus some real multiple of
another vector right uh lambda
and then i've got x2 y2
z2 okay so the reason why this works the
reason why this works
and this didn't work is because in fact
this is shorthand for three equations
what we call three
parametric equations right
this one equation has tied inside it
x equals and then i look at all the x
parts
i compare all those x components because
they don't interact they're orthogonal
to the y and z so i can treat them
separately right
x equals x one plus lambda x two
y equals y one plus lambda
y two z equals z1
plus lambda z2 these
are what we call the parametric
equations and
the specific parameter that you use
actually can i just ask because um this
would usually sit into
extension one have you been introduced
formally to the language of the
parameter have you seen that
yeah you may be familiar with it from
the unit circle for example
um bless you um on the unit circle
right we would say yeah you can give me
a cartesian equation for this
x squared plus y squared equals 1.
but you can also say well i can describe
every point
not just in terms of an x and a y i can
describe it in terms of a single number
the angle of rotation
and that angle is called the parameter
give me a theta and i'll tell you where
you are on the circle
here give me a lambda and i'll tell you
where you are on the line does that make
sense
give me a lambda equals zero band there
i am on a
give me a lambda of one there i'm on b
uh give me a lambda of a half
i'm the midpoint etc etc does this make
sense
so we shouldn't be that surprised that
this here didn't work to give us a line
because it was a vastly
underpowered tool you really need three
equations which
mathematics mathematicians being lazy
they combine into one
and we write it in this very succinct
way does that make sense
okay let's see if we can do an example
together of
finding the equation of um some
arbitrary
set of points that's together i've got
some coordinates ready here i just need
to find
where i hid them
okay here's my example i'm gonna give
you an a and a b
and uh we're gonna see if we can find
the vector equation of the line that
passes through these two points so
here's my example a let's go with
negative one
two negative 4 and then for b i'm going
to go
3 negative 2 negative
3. now i'm not going to give you too
much of a leg up into this i think you
have enough
geometric reasoning you've got to work
out how to get from one
to here and then sort of along the line
as it were
see if you can work out off of what i've
drawn here what the
vector equation of this line is going to
look like i'll give you a few minutes
if you get what you think is an answer
call me over if you're beating
your head against the wall also signal
to me but i will show it to everyone
okay off you go let's have a play with
this now
what i'm going to do in fact is
hopefully show you two ways to do this
just to confirm we're doing this right
so in order to get the vector equation
of line a b
right at least in the scheme that i've
shown you i need to know what u is
i need to know what v is and lambda is
just kind of
uh yeah it's any number right so just i
just leave that pronumeral okay
now you can see here i've stated that u
is o a to get from the origin
up to a right so in this case because
you've just been given the coordinates
of a it is not difficult to write um the
vector o a which i'm labeling as little
u
the x and the y and the z of this vector
correspond to
the x and the y and the z of the
coordinates is that okay so hopefully
without too much trouble we were okay
to write down this part here yes
now only a little bit of extra work is
required to do v
v is a b right so i've called
this a b
how do i determine the vector that gets
me from
a to b
o b minus o a we could do a simple
vector diagram here to show us this
right but you've done this enough times
you like i can just go straight i don't
need to draw the diagram
i know what's going on i can just think
about well what will i do to a
for each of these x y and z's to get
them to be you could even just state it
right
from negative one what do you do to have
to get to three
you add four right from two what do you
have to do to get to negative two
you subtract four and then from negative
four to negative three
just be careful with the signs you add
one
so that's v you okay with that so
therefore
this is that was the hardest part of the
work the vector equation
is you start with you
you add some multiple of
v done that wasn't too
hard was it now as promised i want to
show you another way to do this
because this is not the only way to
state the vector equation
there were some assumptions built into
this right that don't have to be used
i said go from o to a and by though this
has a special name so we should label it
together
going from o to a it sort of gets you
onto the line right it gets you
in position as well so this initial
vector here is called the
position vector and sometimes the
question will ask
find the position vector this is what
they mean get me onto the line
and then they say well you've got this
vector here
which is not about position it's about
well which way is the line facing which
way is it going in other words which
direction
do you point from the position so
therefore a natural name for it would be
now the traditional name is direction
vector i can see why i think a
displacement vector is kind of
a um related idea but we've used
displacement vector elsewhere
in our in our thinking right um so this
is what they generally call direction
because you're here looking in what
direction okay now think about this with
me
for line a b is there not an infinite
series of choices for our position
vector anything
on a b could be a position vector right
and there's at least one other option
that i could use instead of a
like easily i could just use b do you
agree so
let's just quickly jot down right if i
were to do
a different position vector like say
what is it 3 negative 2
negative 3 right i'm still going to have
some
multiple of but it'll be a different
direction vector
if i use this scheme i go from b to a
right so i could go ahead i can work out
what ba is
but guess what mathematicians we love
being lazy
don't we do i really have to work out
what ba is because ba is just minus a b
right so because this captures every
possible real number
i've already got a suitable direction
vector
right do you agree because what i've got
here is i'm now going to b
and i've already got v it's there it's
i'm still on the line and every other
multiple of v
will still be on the line just different
start point so that makes sense
so just like with in the 2d world in
cartesian equations there's an
infinite variety of different ways to
write the equation of the same line
same deal for vector equations of lines
does that make sense
okay let me hit pause there we're not
done with vector equations of lines
there's more stuff to learn
um probably the only thing to highlight
before you get going on the exercise is
this is very similar is it not two
when you thought about just cartesian
equations of lines in 2d
we would normally write y equals say mx
plus b
that's a very common way to write it but
just for reasons that i hope will become
clear in about 10 seconds i'm going to
write it
backwards
can you see why this feels or
should feel a lot like the vector
equation of a line we've got because
what are you doing right
it's like go to a place some location
some position
and then tell me which direction i
should face is this a steep line is it
shallow is it horizontal etc
right so this is kind of like your
position and this is kind of your
direction
same deal same principle so if i
asked you hey i've got two lines
i've got their vector equations can you
tell me whether these lines are parallel
or not
which part of this would you care about
just the direction vector
i didn't care about where it's
positioned it's just the direction what
about if i wanted to know
where the two lines were perpendicular
what would i do i would look at the
direction vectors because they tell me
where it's facing
and i want a dot product of zero because
that means they're exactly orthogonal to
each other does that make sense
so you have all the pieces there right
you just need to fit them together in
the questions